so congratulations first of all on
season two of prodigal son
um that must have been really good news
hearing that
yeah it was very fun and i'm i you know
overjoyed that we were able to come back
to work during this time and and make
some entertainment for everyone
yeah so you have this you know extended
break that a lot of people obviously
yourself included didn't expect because
of the pandemic from season one to
season two and that can be
scary for a brand new show and yet you
guys seem to have picked up
more fans during that break so why do
you think that is
i think i mean every time i watch our
show it
it still surprises me like i watched the
um episode one and two of season two and
and i'm laughing and i i just
i think it's that it's it's a show that
you can't really uh predict
um each episode and and uh it's
definitely not something that you
okay it's a show about serial killers
and then oh but it's funny and then it's
gross and then it's
you know and i think it's very unique in
that way and i don't think there's any
other show
like it on television so i'm really
happy that um
and i don't know how they do it really
like it's a very um precise mix of
everything
um that we somehow managed to pull off
and
i'm really happy we do and people seem
to be enjoying it which is great
well after this extended break how nice
was it kind of getting back together
with everybody on set
obviously protocols were in place but it
must have just been nice to see
everybody again
yeah it is i i think i think we're very
lucky that we are coming back for a
season two because we all know each
other
um the crew included so it's nice to see
familiar faces and
because i i think it would be very hard
to start a new show now
um because you don't see people until
actually like i the crew like i never
see their faces
you know um and it's i only see the cast
in between
uh action and cut so it's been weird in
that sense that you're not really
connecting with people in the way that
you would um
when we first started um the first thing
i had was with bellamy
and i think we were both like i think
i'm really over acting
because it was just like oh my god this
is my face look at my face i can see
your face you know it's like
it was a whole um weird experience when
we started back
definitely um especially being i mean we
film in new york and i'm in new york now
and everyone west masks the entire time
if i leave my apartment
in my building i'm wearing my mask so
we've just gotten so used to not seeing
people's faces
um but so to be able to um
work on the show and and interact with
other people
and then we've had like big emotional
scenes and big action scenes and stuff
and like
to to be able to trade emotions with
another human being is a bit of a gift
at this moment
i know things we took for granted before
and now you're like oh no this is i'm
glad we can do this again
yeah um you know the season two premiere
i touched on the death of george floyd
and and the black lives matter movement
what was the discussion like on set in
terms of
tackling real world issues like racism
and how it will affect characters this
season
well i think uh in the off time um
frank uh had a lot of discussions with
chris and sam the
creators about the best way to tackle
that um in my mind when i heard that we
were doing it um
i was i mean it just makes complete
sense there's we
have an incredibly diverse um police
unit on the show
like i'm the only white person in that
in that room when we have the
case meetings and all that kind of stuff
and so it would be kind of weird
if we didn't at least talk about it um
but they
they put a storyline in which is great
and
you know for me as i've been just
talking to someone else about it
it's like you know we have a show about
serial killers which exist
in the world um and this also exists in
the world and why does one make you more
uncomfortable than the other
or probably makes you more uncomfortable
because you just don't want to have to
deal with the fact that
it exists well guess what other people
have to deal with that
all the time and um and the sooner you
realize that the sooner we can move on
actually if we if we confront it and and
make some changes and
if you don't want to talk about it well
we have to talk about it now
and then then we won't have to because
we can hopefully fix the problem
so i think i'm i'm very um happy that i
mean it would just be bizarre if we
didn't i
i it made complete sense to me i was
like yeah why why wouldn't we talk about
that it's not
i think that's just like we're like i
said at the beginning about our show
it's such a
mix of everything um one minute you're
laughing the next minute you're crying
and it
and it it's challenging you mean i think
that's i think that's great i think we
should do that
yeah that's so well said no i completely
agree with you okay so
obviously he didn't commit the murder
but malcolm is quite conflicted
by the murder of endicott so how do you
think that's going to play on his psyche
going through this season um
well he's holds this um secret from
ainsley he's lied to ainsley so he
is now um which he thinks he's get he's
you know he's kind of getting away with
and
and making sure she's okay but obviously
that's a whole other stress
on his life that he's given himself um
and so
every time he's with ainsley he's like
oh god i hope she's not finding out
and then of course his father knows all
about it so he's pressing his buttons
and wants to talk about
murder and chopping up bodies and all
this kind of stuff the whole time
and um i don't think malcolm has really
figured out the best way to deal with
any of it
um i think season one he figured out uh
his relationship with his dad and how he
could
deal with that um in a better way in a
more healthy way of himself
but now he's holding this big secret and
he
um is a bit more afraid of himself and
he does
kind of want to talk about it and the
only person he can talk to about is his
dad
um who's the last person who wants to
talk to you about anything
but so then i mean it's very stressful
to play
because he just the character is just
constantly being pushed and pulled in
every different direction
um and struggling with what he wants to
talk about and what he can't talk about
um i mean a lot of the relationships in
the show
are similar to everyone's relationships
with their parents or with themselves
and they're just made way bigger because
of the circumstances that we put the
characters in
on the show but they're all things that
i can pull from my own life
yeah yeah difficult conversations you
know there are
there are many things that i'd love to
talk to my parents about that find very
difficult to talk to you know it's
it's those things so it's not hard to
get into that and then you just
dial it up to 11 and um cry a bit more
yeah okay can we just talk about how
great michael sheen is
yeah he's close he's amazing
amazing um why do you think he plays
such a good serial killer like what is
it about him and his acting like how
does he nail that so well
uh michael has a really um i mean first
of all he's just a
phenomenal actor um who doesn't
i mean then they've given him like this
character is very fun
and they've the writers are brilliant at
writing to everyone's strengths and um
but michael has he's just very
he has a very um steady
uh like a like a solid core underneath
everything else like he and but he's
also a very caring person
um i mean he's he's not a zero killer
but he has all of these that makes
mixes that when you put them together um
make for make for a very entertaining
character and someone that you can't
take your eyes off really um
the focus of that cell adds a lot to the
um to the show as well and even for us
like if as soon as you're walking down
that corridor and you go into that door
and it's close behind you
there is that there's such a an intense
focus
um i watched michael in an interview uh
yesterday where he was talking about the
fact that um
we've spent more time together as our
characters than we have as people
um which is true it's really weird
because we spend a lot of time together
as people
as well but but we really have spent
more time together as our characters
but it's really fun um to be able to do
that because
michael is so capable as an actor that
all you have to do is come prepared
and then just see where the scene takes
you and that's really fun
and those scenes in that cell it's like
it's like a play you know you walk in
and and it's just you too and
it's a lot of fun to play with and i'm
just so happy that i have such an
amazing
scene partner in michael that was when i
got the job i literally was jumping up
and down
in my in my house like oh my god i get
to do
scenes with michael i'm so excited yeah
because i i was really excited to
work for him okay so this might be a
tough question but who is your
favorite on screen like either in movies
or tv
serial killer
um well there's no question if he is or
not but uh but christian bale in
american psycho
it's such a good movie and he does it so
well um there are so many different
aspects to that character and um our
show wears its influences on its sleeve
and um there's definitely uh like in
that first episode there's definitely
shades of
um american psycho and patrick bateman
and
and joker and like all these different
things are in there
and i love that we do that um yeah yeah
but yeah
patrick bateman that's a good one okay
anything you can tell us about
catherine zeta jones and her character
joining this season
so catherine is playing a doctor who is
at claremont with um
with michael's character and um
what else can i tell you not much i mean
she starts off there i'm sure at some
point
um i will interact with her because i
interact with everyone and i'm intrigued
um in anyone who has any kind of
relationship with my father on the show
is of interest to me um
and so yeah
we're very excited to have her and i
can't wait um
to see where the storyline goes i
actually don't know um where the
storyline's gonna go
um but she started filming yesterday and
and uh yeah so it's very it says a lot
yeah we're very excited to have her and
it says a lot about our show that people
um want to come and play with us yeah
absolutely okay now the last time we
spoke to you was in july of last year
and you had you postpone your wedding
and then at the end of last year we saw
that you got married so how does it feel
now that you're married
it was great i have a ring on now
which is weird for me because i had like
a bit of a phobia of rings and
like that whole de-gloving thing kind of
freaked me out like getting your ring
caught on something and getting your
skin ripped
okay literally never one rings my entire
life but um
but now it's like really it's actually
really nice especially
um when i'm in uh new york and she's in
los angeles like
i have to take my ring off for work um
but at the end of the day it's really
nice to put it back on again it's like
really soppy but it is
like i really like putting it back on at
the end of the day um
and it just makes you feel you know it's
hard right now because you know we're
married and we're not seeing each other
especially in a lot
due to covid and it's not you can't just
you fly across the country
um so it's nice to have that that
connection um still
um so yeah we wanted to end the year on
a nice note um and actually
i have there's no way that we could have
done it in front of 150 people that we
were planning on it like
jen was a mess like she had to give me
her vows to read like it was like a
whole thing
and we did it like like nobody there at
our house
so um it was nice it was it was how it
was supposed to be i think
oh i love that thanks for sharing that
and real quick to wrap things up you
know you're on this hit show
you just got married do you feel like
you've kind of found that nice balance
between your professional life and your
personal life
close i think the hardest thing now as i
just said is that we're not really
seeing each other
as much as we would like to um but the
good thing about
you know getting married and everything
is that it is then about the rest
of your life so it's like okay this is a
part of my life and this is hard now
we're not seeing each other as much as
we would like but this is now
and we did this forever so you know it's
gonna be
we've got a long long life to look
forward to so um but definitely
i i definitely feel um more of an adult
these days
yeah i love that you just had to get
married there you go
that's it that's it i get it you start
wearing a ring
yeah uh it was so great getting to talk
to you thanks so much congrats on all
this success on the show and i can't
wait to see where it's going to go this
season
thank you yeah okay see you later
you